Oh
can I get my Nona
I also could speak very loudly so I was
her last year with somebody mayor
thank you so I wanted to start by asking
how many of you deal with populist New
Age man how many of you have hit a
pothole thank you now how many of you
hear from citizens
how many of you complaining about
no layers when you book to proactively
manage the largest assets that you throw
your city raise your hand if you like
that
I'm Courtney Ehrlichman of the
co-founder of robotics which spun out of
hurting eval university's robotics
Institute after four years of research
deploying in the real world testing in
the city of Pittsburgh the
municipalities around the region and
about almost a million dollars and
investing from the federal government
and philanthropist so basically what we
do is we take ubiquitous access that are
already out on your street everyone here
has a smartphone and half of them are
out in your laps in the audience and
there are already cars and bikes riding
all around your streets what if we just
married the to make a smartphone sensor
your